this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical
images and videos to use in lectures
courses
presentations professional training and
more for more information
click on the link in the description
please watch this entire video
before caring for your drain this video
will teach you
how to take care of your surgical drain
surgical drains remove fluid from under
your skin near your surgical site
this helps prevent infection and
encourages healing
a surgical drain consists of a drain
tube that runs from your surgical site
to a bulb that collects the fluid
you strip the drain tube to keep it
clear and remove
any clots or blockages then you empty
the bulb when it is half
full or as instructed by your health
care
provider you will need alcohol wipes
a measuring cup and a drainage record
sheet
be sure to wear disposable gloves if
your health care provider says you
should
be careful not to pull on the tubing you
should not feel any tugging where the
tube enters your skin
step one wash your hands with soap and
water
and then dry them step 2
put on disposable gloves if your
healthcare provider says you should
step 3 look for clots or blockages that
may prevent the fluid from flowing
out of the tube and into the bulb some
clots may be hidden inside the tube
under your skin step 4
loosen the clots by gently squeezing the
tube surrounding them
step 5 use one hand to hold the drain
tube in place where it leaves your skin
step six use your other hand to pinch
the tube with an alcohol wipe
between your finger and thumb step seven
slide your pinched fingers along the
tube
to force any fluid out of the tube and
into the bulb
you may need to repeat steps five
through seven several times to clear the
tube
try not to let go of the tube between
steps
if fluid remains in the tube or you
accidentally let go
repeat steps five through seven using a
new alcohol wipe
do not allow the bulb to become more
than half full
too much fluid in the bulb reduces its
ability to remove fluid from underneath
your skin
now you will begin emptying the bulb
step 8 hold the bulb lower than your
incision
so that fluid moves out of the tube and
into the bulb
step 9 point the bulb away from your
body
never squeeze the bulb before taking the
cap off
step 10 remove the cap never touch the
opening with your bare hands
step 11 hold the measuring cup under the
bulb
step 12 turn the bulb upside down and
squeeze the fluid into the cup
step 13 after removing the fluid
continue squeezing the bulb and use a
new alcohol wipe to clean the top
step 14 while still squeezing the bulb
put the cap back on the top the
depressed bulb
creates suction that continuously
removes fluid from underneath your skin
step 15 read the amount of fluid in the
measuring cup
step 16 write the amount on your record
sheet
step 17 empty and rinse the cup as
directed
keep the bulb below the level of your
incision to help the fluid move out of
the tube
and into the bulb contact your surgeon
if you notice the amount of fluid
suddenly increases or decreases
the odor of the fluid changes the fluid
contains pus
or becomes thicker over time your drain
tube
falls out or your incision opens
your incision is red swollen painful
or has pus coming out or your
temperature
is 101 degrees fahrenheit or higher